I don't think people understand how
practical karma is I actually think it's
the single most practical thing in the
world I think it's just a genuine belief
that the more selfless you are capable
of being the more likely what you want
selfishly will happen and I think that's
just a point of view that's a
perspective a leap of faith I think all
of us are byproducts of our environment
our DNA how we were parented and we all
go different tracks and I think that
most people unfortunately come from a
place of scarcity and thus they're
trying to hoard for themselves I think
when you're blessed or lucky enough to
come from a place of abundance what
you're talking about becomes very easy
it's just how I see the world I think
that the more one can lean into giving
back in all shapes and sizes the more
that the world will keep them propped up